Connor Thank you for joining me why are
you doing this interview oh because I
feel like a lot of people have
speculated no time to say what they want
to say and um I've never never been able
to speak on it
the court of public opinion has been
pretty Savage about what's happened I
think it's because when the public hear
anything about drugs in sport or
cheating or anything like that they
immediately assume the worst and my most
of the time they're right to assume that
let's be honest about it
you're in that horrible position for any
Sportsman where you failed two drug
tests and you're trying to prove your
innocence but you've probably seen what
social media has been saying how has
that impacted on you I mean it's been
brutal
um you know it does feel like a Witch
Hunt I've never seen anything quite like
this before in any other athlete whether
they've raised their hands to it or you
know they've just taken a small ban you
know I was willing to fight for my
innocence and improve my innocence
although there was an easy way out in
the beginning in lying and saying oh I
may have accidentally done this I may
have done this by accident and taken a
small six-month ban instead I've chose
to fight this because my Integrity mad
more to me and I would never ever ever
raise my hands to something I ain't done
four months ago you're preparing for one
of the biggest fights of your life
against Chris Eubank Jr
everyone was waiting for this huge
anticipation we all remembered what
happened when the two fathers fought I
remember it very well know your dad well
and Chris Eubank senior
um and then your World falls apart
what is that moment like for you when
you heard about the failed drug test
um I didn't think anything of it to be
fair when it was the first one
um when they said they found an adverse
fund and I didn't really think anything
of it really no not at all isn't that
every Sports was a nightmare um no
because I thought there may have been an
era I thought let's run another test
straight away Let's do let's you know
that I know I never even heard of this
thing before this is the first time the
drug which is uh clomiphene which can
boost testosterone levels but I'm 26.
reduce body fat yeah I'm just saying
what it is yes I'm 26 when people are
saying no I may have needed a
testosterone booster I'm 26 years old
yeah I didn't even know what his thing
was at a time so for me I thought okay
you know it may have been you know an
error or an accident somewhere
um along we can find out what's happened
and then when it was when I found out
that you know they've been a second
adverse finding was when I was like okay
now something's actually wrong there's
something wrong here and um what are you
feeling inside yourself at that point
who's done this to me
I generally looked around and I thought
it was the hardest part of this whole
period of everything I've been through
this was the hard part was because I was
looking around and thinking okay
I am actively taking it
it's actively in something or it's
Something's Happened it's definitely
there and these were the thoughts that
were going on through my head who's done
this do you accept this was in your body
I don't accept it was in my body not at
all based on
independent Sciences looking at the
reports based on my own scientists
looking at the reports and what we found
people say you may have paid for the
best legal team
damn right I pay for the best legal team
damn right I pay for the best scientists
my career is on the line my image is on
the line my name is on the line and I
can't be known for this and it was a
more so me employing the best people to
find out what had actually happened what
do you think of people who cheat in
sport it should be banned for life
especially in contact yeah bam for life
you know it's there's no room for it
there's been a fire today who's who's
just had a brain hemorrhage there's no
room for it I know firsthand the damage
it does from my dad with other with Joe
McLennan I was there one side of that
fight I mean both men got stayed in the
hospital both nearly died and you think
I do it and people think I'd do this
it's hard for me because it's like I
turned problem 19 a month with the
public eye and I've seen how hard I work
over the years they've seen you know the
three three in the morning runs they've
seen the nutrition they've seen the
workout appointment with my coaches you
know everyone can vouch for how hard I
work but
that's not good enough normally I would
say the vast majority of times a
sportsman test positive for drugs they
always say I didn't do it invariably and
then almost always it is proven that
they did you're in a strange position
of you're in a kind of mid mid position
right now because the WBC have come back
and they have said uh that they think
there may have been reasons why you had
this in your body but they have made a
presumption it was in your body you
don't even accept that I don't accept
that when they say you may have taken
and he got a lot of attention this and
to mockery yeah but when they said it
may have been a highly elevated
consumption of eggs could have created
this positive testing you you don't even
accept that I don't accept that no the
WBC while I was on the me and my team
won a phone to them um on his own call
they had come out and said that they are
one of their scientists are currently
dealing with two cyclists who have
tested positive for clomiphene traces
um and they can prove this in the
embryos and the eggs I'm not willing to
accept it because the 270 a page report
that I sent over to them what my team
sent over to them had nothing to do with
it it had everything to do with my test
test negative three times and nine days
later testing positive they didn't
conclude they found anything wrong with
the testing
what they did say they said there was no
conclusive evidence that Mr Ben engaged
in intentional or knowing ingestion of
clomathy I don't believe it was there in
the first place you gotta remember I've
never I don't even know what this thing
is coincidentally for my first Vader
test coincidentally for the biggest
fight of my career there's a there's a
substance in my body that I haven't even
heard of the reality is this particular
drug
which is becoming more prevalent in
sport and no one's quite sure why but he
can as I said boost testosterone levels
by 50 it can reduce body fat
um so it clearly would have tangible
benefits on an athlete I mean it would
whoever the athlete is it would help
if someone was doing it deliberately it
would help well definitely but what a
WBC is saying is even a the peak of it
in my system is still only a trace why
don't you give this dossier
270 pages of it why don't you give it to
the British boxing Board of control
because they're ultimately the ones that
can sanction or not sanction your right
to fight in this country my dad tore up
his British boxing license until you're
in the 80s you know the board though
that ain't going to stop me from
fighting they can't stop me from
fighting look it's up to you having a
professional fight in this country in
this country and that's fine so be it is
they filed they filed seven misconduct
charges against me one of them was they
wanted because we wanted the fight to go
ahead the second one was because we
didn't tell Eubank immediately and on
the Monday they said we're upholding all
charges I thought you look and do one
you think I'm gonna sit here and take
this what they've said is will show us
the evidence you've got you've got 270
pages of apparent evidence surely the
smart thing to do whatever your views of
the of the board of control they are the
governing body surely you should just
give them your evidence let them respond
that's down to my legal team you know
people would stop you I don't understand
what stops you my pride the way they've
dealt with this the way they won't get
you through this but I don't have to be
licensed by the board That's My Views
you do the fight in Britain I don't plan
on finding brain anytime soon just put
it all on the internet I want to trust
me what's stopping you the ongoing legal
cases that's that's the only that's the
only thing you seem to look this is your
career your livelihood this is
everything at stake here
isn't it I agree everything's on the
line I agree and this is what I keep
trying to tell my Lord but he can't do
this you can't do that mate this would
have been public I've known what I've
known since December and I've kept quiet
everyone firing everyone attacking me
everyone and I've known what I've known
since December and I'm sitting here
again going well why can't we just
release the information why can't the
public just know what's actually gone on
does the public you know from what I
just I looked at it today social media
is Savage
they've convicted you they think you're
guilty and I'm gonna have to deal with
that I think I think publicly how are
you going to deal with that there will
be there there will be her and your
promoter says look it's time to you've
got to move on to progress what do you
think when when he says that well I
don't think they're I think the public
have made up their mind already
irrelevant of what's presented relevant
of what the boards say I've got strong
DNA and I'm one hell of a fire naturally
I work hard I've made loads of
sacrifices and I'm willing to do what
other people aren't willing to do and
that's why I'm where I am not because of
cheating if you feel this passionately
about it
I can sense it I can sense you're
emotional about this
to be branded achieved in the court of
public opinion what
what has that done to you
um yes it's um
it's um yeah it's hurt me yeah it's um
it's been
um yeah it's hurt me it says
how badly um
I don't think I was going to make it
through this period I didn't think um
I didn't think I was going to make it
through
um you know there's a shame for saying I
ain't even done you know it's hard
because it was like I felt like I was on
different for saying I ain't even done
you know if I had done something wrong
you know I'm human you know I'll raise
my hands to it I made a mistake whatever
it is my personal life whereas I raise
my hand never
neverness and you know I felt like seven
years of hard work and sacrifice and
leaving my family and and the image I
maintained was just you know ruined that
somebody else's incompetence you know it
was um yeah it's um it's been hard for
them that you make it what do you mean
um
I don't think I would um I didn't think
I'd I was taking day by day
I don't think I'd see another day you
were feeling suicide yeah I'd say so
yeah
yeah and it upsets me now because
I I don't know how I got so bad I got in
a really bad way but you got me bro you
gotta remember if if you think I'm
innocent or if you don't think I'm
innocent
I am innocent yeah I mean look let me be
clear I don't know right this is the
first time we've met I know your father
from old I've watched you from afar it's
a module work in a boxing ring I don't
know if you're honest I would never do
this to my family I would never do this
to my supporters you think I'd do this
to my dad
you can do this to my son who's now
gotta grow up and and look her
well look at this
you think I it's not who I am I don't I
don't I've there's been there's been too
many
you know what kind of thing
um just kill yourself people have told
you to kill you kill yourself people
said I'm uh yeah kill yourself racist
comments to my son with my family on
social media yeah
yeah anything in in person in the street
person no never nothing in person
um you know it's cowardly he's cowardly
I think I I don't even think it's social
media that bothers me it's it was more
so the shame I felt leaving the house
although I'd done nothing wrong I you
know I was having night terrors panic
attacks you know
and I don't throw I don't throw these
words out in mental health I was really
struggling I was in a really bad way um
you know and I was coping terribly with
it
um you know I was coping in a really bad
way
how do you know about it
um
still hard for me because it's because I
still can't believe I'm in a situation
you know I still can't believe how much
the public want me to be guilty they saw
boxing pundits you're telling me I'm
guilty boxing band it's telling me I'm
guilty they know me they know my family
you know what I Stand For You Know Who I
Am why are you trying why are you trying
to label me a cheat they're not suing
the labs right
well there there is that so you think I
what manufacturing manipulating and
concealing evidence that I got an
independent scientist the local report
and that's what we've seen from one of
the best letters manipulation
manufacturing but that wasn't verified
by the WBC what the WBC going to come
out and say that's what I mean you've
got to go to the governing body that can
actually go out with this properly do
well it's hard because I want this to be
done I want this to be finished and I
want to resume with my career should I
just sit back and accept the fact that
you're going to sue the board no of
course
for the full loss of earnings damaged
reputation what how much is it because
the board don't the board shouldn't
recognize Vita let me ask this
let's assume for a moment your theory is
right it's a theory it's not proven
scientifically yet and hasn't been
ratified by any governing body but if
your theory is right with contaminated
it would prompt the question well why
who would want to do that uh it would be
in the only way it would be
contamination if he is and whose
interest is it to to ruin this great
fight absolutely I'm not saying it was
the liberal what in the lab I'm not
saying it was the liberal you know it
may be an error in the testing I'm not
saying deliberately I'm not saying that
anyone's in their Labs deliberately done
this it may I'm not saying that at all
but it may be an accident it may be an
error there are millions and millions of
pounds at stake here dollars whatever
you say is this does this all sound from
what I've said about the testing
manipulation manufacturing Casino
evidence from what I'm saying to you
does that sound does that sound listen
you sound like you have a Welter of
information but I cannot for the life of
me understand why you wouldn't then give
it to the the governing body it's down
to them whether you fight in this
country again yeah so I don't understand
that that to me makes sense yeah I can
get a license elsewhere what is that I
mean a lot of time pretty earn is it I
think he's a brilliant promotion he
cares about his Fighters he wants you to
try and move on from this that's that's
his advice right what have you said to
him about that
I just said I need the biggest fight
possible the hardest fight so the when I
beat that person in devastating fashion
there's no questions as to my whole
career there's no questions it's done
that's that's what that's what I want to
do I can't come back I don't need no
warm-up I Don't Need No Easy fight I
don't need a warm-up to get back into it
I'm 26 years old
give me the best name give me the bean
training problem of course I have I've
tried throughout this whole period is it
hard to train properly when you're on
this now it's fine mental state now it's
fine I I struggled there was probably
about two months where I was um yeah I
was in a really bad way you know did you
talk to your dad about it
um I did but my dad was in a bad way as
well
most nights I was didn't want to go to
sleep because if I knew what I had to
wake up to
um
you got me when this is a nightmare for
me
how has this happened how have I how
have I got in this situation my faith
let me down you feel that oh yeah 100
yeah let me bring in your dad who's been
listening to this he's over in Sydney
Nigel I've not talked to you for a long
time we used to have uh a few years
together it's good to see you um I've
got three sons all in their 20s actually
one of whom is is Connor's age and I
can't imagine many tougher things for a
father to have to deal with than
listening to your son talking in such a
profoundly emotional and upsetting way
about feeling suicidal in the last few
weeks and months since all this went
down
how does that first of all make you feel
as a father to hear this
um
Pierce I was actually in the same same
position as my son
um I'm really struggling as well for
myself
I don't really drink
um every night I was drinking like half
a bottle of ring wine and I on on
medication
and um yeah we both we both were in a
dark dark place because um
to me
it looks like this is a Witch Hunt it's
like we're going back to 1800s she's a
witchy the witchy the witch burner
burner yeah hold on a minute that's my
son
the one thing here if I've ever thought
my son was guilty or anything mate I'd
say son I love you but you know what you
gotta deal with this on your own mind
I'd hang him out to dry but I was
actually in this training camp with him
peers I was training with him I would
say on that that there are lots of
benefits to being the son of somebody
famous I've had this conversation with
my sons but there are also disadvantages
Connor will get an irrational amount of
attention because he's your son I don't
understand why there's this compelling
dossier of 270 pages of material why not
make that public and why not give it to
the British boxing board
okay I've listened I agree with you
pierce but
the same way I feel that they're David
McConnor in not these other Fighters is
that uh the same way they dealt with me
listen Nigel I understand your passion I
understand Connor's passion but I also
think if you've gone to all this trouble
to draw up this massive dossier of
evidence and the British boxing board is
asking for it I don't understand how it
can be anything but bad for your case if
you don't hand it over I mean at very
least call their Bluff say right here
you are get them to respond to it I
don't know why if I was in your position
that's what I would do you're like your
father you are your own man right you
are and if you wanted to you could put
this out there tonight
yeah I still don't think that proves
minor sense at all I've just been
cleared by the organization which the
testing which I felt I don't understand
why you wouldn't want to counter that
agenda by making public this dossier
because I don't know what it is they got
him for me I don't know what I don't
know what what Vendetta is yeah but it's
like saying you're accused of killing
someone okay but I've been proven in
this authorities that run that test I
wouldn't say you've been proven innocent
they just couldn't just give me the
clear they've said they said there was
no conclusive evidence just to be clear
exactly what they said right it's not an
absolutely unequivocal you're definitely
Innocent but it's certainly not
unhelpful I've seen Sportsman come back
from this when they've gone through the
process
yeah I I do agree with you
um I don't know what the legal side of
it but yeah I I me personally and I love
my son you know and I know for a fact
that he's an innocent man Nigel as a
again as speaking as a father now
you know Connor taught very movingly
about you know sobbing every night while
talking to you you're in Australia the
other part of the world you know the
time zones you're drinking you're
feeling terrible too those conversations
must be some of the most painful you've
ever had in your life right what did you
say to Connor in those in those
conversations to try and stop him from
as he put it you know considering taking
his life
uh I'll be honest with you because it
was like
I come I'm here because I was kind of
for five months
I was in I wasn't here I was in England
moving so while he was going through
this period like I I was there within my
state I'd stay until January uh and then
after and then my mum died so I had so
much pressure on me
and I was just a mess and and so I was
an actually really good talk on it
because actually I was trying to be
strong but there again it was like a
wiley without I you know he was dealing
with me so I'm gonna try to deal with
mine and and we struggled and we
struggled we we both got through to go
thank God Nigel I've got a I've got to
wrap wrap it unfortunately what I would
say to you Connor is I I feel that
you're in a lot of pain about this
that's clear and I'm extremely sorry
you've been going through what you've
been going through because nobody should
ever feel that way and it's it's awful
and the court of public opinion on
social media could be particularly
brutal experience myself it's a very
very unpleasant thing
but I also think you can turn that round
But ultimately this may be down to you
deciding what you want to do with your
life and your future and your career I
mean what is the dream for you out of
this hell just about fighting the fines
the easy part the fine this has been the
hardest five I've ever had to face
the fight is the easy part that's that's
no I bought a bonfire and it's in my
blood
well Connor I wish you well in in
pursuing this I'm not going to make a
judgment until it's all concluded you
know the facts are what they are as we
know them but the facts can develop you
know if there is genuinely new
information which exonerates you my
advice is get it out there thank you so
thank you very much and Nigel I
appreciate you joining me from Australia
it's very early over there and I thank
you also for your calendar thank you
very much
thank you and tell Connor get that thing
off his top lick
well that is a problem I agree yeah some
things fathers can't just get something
to do all my sons have weird facial hair
it's gonna stop I agree hey good to talk
to you now I've just been been a while
and I appreciate you joining me